T
THERE.
>> BUT IT GETS US DIRECTLY INTO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT NOW,
AND WE CAN REACT TO THAT ONE AS
WELL BECAUSE THIS ONE IS OUT OF
LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL IN THE
THROES OF MORE CONTROVERSY WITH
COUNCIL MEMBER, KEVIN DE LEÓN,
FACING FRESH SCRUTINY AFTER
DRAMATIC VIDEO SHOWING HIM IN A
PHYSICAL FIGHT WITH A COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD LOOK, RIGHT?
EARLIER THIS YEAR HE FACED
CALLS FOR SURE STEPPING DOWN
AFTER LEAKED AUDIO OF DE LEON
AND OTHER MEMBERS THAT THEY
WERE MAKING RACIST COMMENTS.
CNN'S NICK WATT, IN LOS ANGELES,
FOR US GOOD MORNING TO NICK.
THE NEW VIDEO IS STUNNING BUT
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER CHAPTER IN
WHAT HAS BECOME A SAGA FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COUNCIL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT DON.
LISTEN, THAT AUDIO LEAKED A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO.
IT WAS SECRETLY RECORDED DURING
A MEETING ON REDISTRIBUTING A
LOT OF VERY UNPLEASANT THINGS
WERE.
SIDE NOW KEVIN DE LEÓN THE
DEMOCRATIC CITY COUNSELOR CREW
CLEARLY HOPED THAT IT WOULD ALL
BLOWN OVER BY THEN.
HE'S JUST TRYING TO DIP HIS
TOES BACK INTO PUBLIC WATER AND
IT REALLY DIDN'T GO WELL.
>> RESIGN KEVIN!
>> KEVIN DE LEÓN IS WEARING THE
SANTA HAT.
A WOUNDED LION OF L.A.
POLITICS.
GREEN JACKET, THAT'S JASON
REEDY, COMMUNITY ACTIVIST.
THEN, A QUICK DESCENT INTO FOUL
MANDATE FACE-OFF.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THE SANTA HEAD FALLS.
THIS WAS A HOLIDAY PARTY.
OKAY, THERE IS BACK STORY HERE.
IN OCTOBER, SOME YEAR OLD AUDIO
LEAKED, CITY COUNCIL PRESIDENT
LOUIS MARTINEZ TALKING ABOUT A
FELLOW COUNCIL MEMBER, AND HIS
KID.
>> THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO
TO CONTROL HIM, AND --
>> TRANSLATION, LITTLE MONKEY.
SHE APOLOGIZED AND LATER
RESIGNED.
ON THE TAPE SHE ALSO SAID
COUNCILMAN MIKE BONE AND USES
HIS SON LIKE AN ACCESSORY.
DELAY OWN APPEARED TO AGREE,
MADE A JOKE.
OFFICIALLY CENTERED, BUT DE
LEON HAS BEEN WITH LAYING VERY
LOW.
HE REFUSES TO RESIGN.
THE LEONE IS A HIGH-PROFILE.
HE TOOK IT OUT THAT THE L.A.
MAYOR'S JOB, HE SERVED AS
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE OF THE
STATE CEMENT.
HE WON IN THE PRIMARY FOR U.S.
SENATE SEAT.
WELL KNOWN ALOFT TO GO BY AN
ACRONYM, KATIE AL.
HE CLAIMS JASON REEDY WAS THE
AGGRESSIVE.
REALLY LAUNCHED A PELVIC THRUST
LONG FOLLOWED BY AHEAD BUT TO
MY FOREHEAD.
MY RESPONSE IN DEFENSE OF
MYSELF WAS TO PUSH HIM OFF ME.
REEDY GAVE THIS VIDEO TO THE
LAPD WHERE WAITING ON COMMENT
FROM POLICE.
RADY DID NOT INITIATE PHYSICAL
CONTACT WITH ANYONE, HIS LAWYER
TOLD CNN.
NOT ONLY HAS KEVIN DE LEÓN LOST
ALL POLITICAL LEGITIMACY, HIS
CLAIMS WAS EITHER ONE WHO TALKS
HERE, SIMPLY UNDERSCORES HOW
HE'S LOST TOUCH WITH REALITY.
WHILE APPEARING TO GRAB HOLD OF
A CONSTITUENT.
>> NOW, ALL THIS COMES AT A
MOMENT OF HISTORY FOR LOS
ANGELES.
YESTERDAY KAREN BASS WAS SWORN
IN AS THE FIRST FEMALE MAYOR OF
THE CITY, THE FIRST FEMALE OF
COLOR TO SERVE AS A MAYOR OF
THE CITY, AND SHE HAS SERIOUS
THINGS TO WHICH IS DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY ON
HOMELESSNESS, MORE THAN 40,000
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS IN THIS
CITY RIGHT NOW.
SO WITH ALL THAT IS THE
BACKDROP, DON, AS YOU SAY
WRESTLING LIKE THIS, REALLY